madame ait un bateau n'est pas de
vacances pour la science six élèves âgés
de 9 à 12 11 fait travailler leurs
méninges lors d'un stage ce mercredi 26
décembre à montigny le bretonneux
leur objectif créer une balle
rebondissante en utilisant des
techniques de chimistes du coup je vais
tous les pots dans dans le mélange de
bord axé de farine la maïzena
du coup ça va se durcir ça va en faire
une petite est une petite boule entre
guinée fait informe une couche sur la
colle en force de la trace d'armes ans
une sur une boule d'une balle
rebondissante et pratiquer la scion sous
forme ludique une expérience proposée
par ce lieu depuis l'été dernier les
expériences scientifiques en fait pour
c'est un moyen de manipuler de découvrir
de se poser des questions donc on leur
fait pas du tout en cours
le but est qu'ils sentent bien et qu'ils
soient amenés à se poser même des
questions après après espère après une
heure de manipulation et de tests dans
ce laboratoire premières conclusions de
ces albert einstein en herbe
j'ai très bien la cha cha cha et
parentaux début chaque mois je pensais
que cela
et les foules ou en auraient besoin de
plus de matière à la fin du stage tous
ces apprentis sont repartis avec un
diplôme et le sentiment d'avoir fait
progresser la science
de quoi susciter de futures vocations